- But I have something funny
that I heard that you did
that I can't believe you did.
And I wouldn't even do if I lost a dare.
You put your phone number on the internet?
- Yeah.
(laughs)
People can hit me up,
you know what I'm sayin'?
917-540-5512.
- That's amazing!
- Yeah, yeah, I've been
textin' with people.
I don't answer all the time, all the time.
But I definitely answer
people and connect with people
and try to send encouraging messages,
whether video or text.
- That's so cool.
- Just trying to keep people
uplifted.
- Elevated, yeah.
- Yeah, it's really cool.
It's a really cool way to
just stay in touch with people
and just give people love.
I just wanted to connect with the people
and it was a great opportunity
to be able to do it
in a cool way.
And it really is true,
it really is my number.
And it works, so it's cool.
- That's really cool of you!